hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
scientific notation scientific notation
is a style of writing numbers to make
them a little more manageable it's used
particularly for numbers that are very
very small or very very big for example
the length of a bacterial cell is on
average zero point zero zero zero zero
zero two meters that's kind of a lot of
zeros so it can be simplified by writing
it in scientific notation in this case
two times 10 to the negative 6 meters
scientific notation is also used for
very very big numbers for example the
number of bacteria on average in the
human body is 90 trillion that is 13
zeros so instead of having to write out
all of these zeros one can simply write
this number in scientific notation and
you can see that that makes these
extreme numbers more manageable now
let's talk about how you get from this
type of number to this type of number
the type of number like this that is not
in scientific notation is called
standard notation and it is
distinguished from this type of number
scientific notation by two parts that is
every number in scientific notation
has a part called the coefficient
and a part called the power of 10 now a
couple of rules for getting these
correct the coefficient is always at
least one but smaller than 10 and you
can see that here the two and the nine
are both at least one but smaller than
10 the power of 10 is the part that
comes next so 10 to the minus 6 or 10 to
the 13th those are powers of 10 and
important to make sure that you get the
sign correct whenever you have a very
small number so the standard notation
that is less than 1 you're going to have
a negative exponent so the negative 6 on
the power of 10 whatever you have a very
very big number that exponent is going
to be a positive number so here the 13
is positive now let's do a couple of
examples in taking standard notation and
converting them to scientific notation
for example with 36,000 the key is
following the decimal points in 36,000
there is an understood decimal right
here and it's going to move until it
gets to a place where the coefficient is
at least one but smaller than 10 in this
case 3.6 so the decimal will move one
two three four four places to where it
separates the 3 in the six that gives us
a coefficient of three point six and
here the power of 10 is 4 but don't
forget the sign he
cuz this is a big number we confirm that
the floor here is positive so three
point six times ten to the fourth is a
scientific notation for 36,000 let's do
another example this time with a small
number zero point zero zero one three
five again we move the decimal point to
get it to the right place for
coefficient here we're going to move it
one two three three places and our
coefficient becomes one point three five
and again that coefficient is at least
one that's smaller than 10 and now it's
time for our power of 10 we write x 10
and here we double-check the places at
the decimal moved one two three places
but here because this is a small number
smaller than one this exponent has a
negative sign so point zero zero one
three five is the standard notation the
scientific notation for the same number
is one point three five times 10 to the
negative 3 that's it for today thank you
for watching and we'll see you next time